you're running for your life down a
hallway
and right before you can expose the
imposter in your group
you're killed forced to roam the map as
a ghost
no wait no
i couldn't do it that line was on
the liars evade detection and your
teammates start throwing out accusations
amongst themselves instead
we saw a some kill white he just killed
he just killed dean
round after round the killer spin lies
and in the end
they take the w leaving the people who
trusted them the most
stunned and confused if toast wins
he's the biggest brain gamer i've ever
seen because there have been double
kills
[Music]
this is among us the game where you
learn
to trust nobody can i trust daphne
chad you think i can trust that dude
my best friend clint he's my best friend
to do
oh white white white white white white
white white white white i just saw white
vent
no get the f away
oh no no no no i knew it
oh my god let's go what did you know
ninja you didn't know
[ __ ]
friendships are being tested all around
the world right now
and it's because of among us yep she's
smiling it's her
melina i i've been i've been i've been
with i've been with melania for 14 years
she cannot lie
oh man that's like something
she's like yeah dude you're so trapped
i'm thanks to the mafia s
gameplay where between one and three
people are designated as an imposter
whose whole
goal is to kill all the other crewmates
without getting caught
we're quickly finding out who amongst
our friend group is a master of
deception
okay
you improved you're really good now dude
we [ __ ] fat we popped off these
clubman
yeah sofia go on i
or on the flip side we're also learning
which friend can psychoanalyze people
like their [ __ ] sherlock holmes
i'm gonna psychoanalyze john's here
all right all right i've been analyzing
him for the past week
when he's imposter and he gets accused
he will
start the sentence with two words why
or how and you just said how bye you
know what
for toast youtube video i'm voting drive
you want to go with the top on this
you're going to toast word on this
this is
youtube
among us is dominating both live
streaming and general gaming as a whole
not only is it the second most watched
game on twitch but its player base is
currently exploding the game has 1.5
million concurrent players
which is pretty crazy considering that
it was a bit of a flop when it first
launched in 2018. like innersloth's
other game dig to china among us was
released on smartphones with only local
multiplayer
it's a game you play together with your
friends in the same room just like other
social deduction games like mafia or
secret hitler
even though among us wasn't a huge
success right away inner sloth continued
to work on it adding things like online
multiplayer and eventually releasing it
on steam the game received constant
updates like new maps and it eventually
started to gain a solid player base
around the world but among us
wouldn't become the crazy sensation it
is today
until last july when sodapoppin got his
hands on it
all right what is among us oh so this is
the town of salem type game
like most of his streams sodapopping was
just doing the usual playing random
games
but after he got bored of a horror game
he was playing he decided to check out
among us which was recommended to him by
pluto
his friend and the twitch staffer that
got him his five
thousand dollar pecunia sweater this
feels so good
oh my god imagine not having a vacuna
sweater
oh my god vacunia it even sounds better
than cashmere
with pluto's help soda learned enough
about the game that he wanted to try it
out for real
so he started wrangling friends in order
to set up a lobby
hey this is a cross-play mobile game so
hop in
i have a computer you don't
yeah but i thought you would just prefer
a phone
yeah yeah okay so we're gonna keep
factory or do you guys want to go
reserves because if it goes
and it just took one game in a small
six-person lobby for the lies to begin
okay so the imposter can't use anything
because they can't do any tasks
they have to kill which means you get a
melee range and you
them no we're dead in here this is a
body well soda's initial lobby started
out pretty small
over the course of the next couple of
hours more and more streamers started
joining
because nobody wanted to miss out on the
fun [ __ ] going down
what are we playing again it's called
among us on steam
it's five bucks my audience is losing
their minds right now i just stopped
the 90-day beyonce in the middle of a
just climb after
the episode yeah my chat's so angry i
stopped tarkov
they're so mad at me right now yeah my
chest so angry i stopped jerking off on
camera
by the end of that stream soda caught
the among us
bug and unlike other random games that
he stops playing after a while
soda came back for more who who are you
i'm vigorous too okay i walked with you
i'm bigger
one
but he wasn't the only person in that
day one lobby who fell in love with the
game
almost everyone who was playing that day
continued to play
and introduced the game to even more and
more streamers
okay i'm sorry felix but the four of us
were cleared on the first kill on the
kills they we were clear on these
and we said i guess
everybody was trying to get nine other
friends to play the game
even if it meant that their trust in one
another would be completely destroyed by
the end of the night
hell streamers even created a giant
among us discord server to make it
easier to start up games
in other words among us took over twitch
with all of your favorite streamers
lying screwing each other over
and murdering each other all in the name
of fun it's hilariously [ __ ] up when
you think about it
did shorty just take the vent i just saw
shorty
take the vent in front of my eyes you
jumped on my ass
early on and you kept saying you had no
tasks when you had taxes
exactly exactly either way
you think your five head that's no zero
eyeballs i'm sorry for using my eyes i
don't need my brain for that [ __ ]
wow but among us wasn't just providing
hours of content for streamers it was
also boosting their viewership
on one hand you have guys like russell
who's been grinding the game going from
an average of 600 viewers
to almost 3 thousand god forbids
train x you see moxie russell gets on oh
my god
oh my god please let me let me let me
wait a minute did he just mention
russell's name as a big streamer
what is my life dude did he really just
mention russell as a big streamer that
people try to leech off
of now i'm so damn proud dude on the
other hand you have already
big streamers like valkyrie exploding in
viewership thanks to among us
just a few weeks ago she had 40 000
people tune in as her and her friends
goofed around
and murdered each other honestly
the coolest thing that among us has done
for streaming is that we're now seeing
all these different communities come
together
big streamers are playing with smaller
streamers lily pichu is hosting ms
kiff and s fans meeting t-pain tv we
haven't met before
can i call you t or mr payne i don't
know i'm
no call
we've even got one of the most unlikely
friendships blooming between disguised
toast and train wrecks i don't know why
like this is weird because like me and
toast i feel like me and toast
without among us i don't think we would
have ever been friends ever
i just don't see it but right now i
don't know why like with among us
like i see him like just like talking to
him and breaking
stuff down with him i [ __ ] love him
like i almost have a little bit of a
crush on him loki i love him
what's funny is that despite among us
being at its peak in terms of popularity
soda's pretty much done streaming the
game himself
see you next time thanks for watching
enjoy among us
have fun on twitch pog champ
but thanks to soda's decision to take a
chance on a friend's recommendation
among us has exploded bringing all sorts
of different twitch communities
together and that's pretty cool
especially when friends turn into
temporary enemies
lies are thrown out left right and
center and lobbies
devolve into complete and utter
chaos
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages